♪♪
Wolfboy:
They think I'm weird mum.
Do you think I'm weird?
It's the dreamers like you who
change this world for the
better.
♪♪
(Laughter)
Kid:
Lame mask.
(Kids Laughing)
♪♪
Wow!
Oof!
♪♪
Hey!
Ahh!
♪♪
(Gasp)
Wolfboy:
What is this place?
(Thump)
You followin' us, pal?
Yeah, pal.
(Beeping noise)
He's a human.
(Gasp)
A human?
♪♪
(Growl)
Zandar:
-Listen up, human,
'cause we're only gonna go over
this once.
Zandar:
We're Sprites, and this is
the Everything Factory.
-Growl
-Oh!
Zandar:
This is where we create things
for the world.
Zandar:
Trees.
-Hello.
Zandar:
The weather.
(Thunder and lightning)
Zandar:
Even life.
♪♪
I love creating things.
Wolfboy:
I make things all the time.
Zandar:
Rabbits don't have wings.
Wolfboy:
Mine does.
You've got a lot to learn
about how the world really
works, human.
♪♪
There's something about him, I
can feel it tickling my beard.
Sprout:
Humans can't see sprites, but he
can see me.
Fascinating.
The three of you must stay in
your dorm until further notice.
No its, no buts, no coconuts.
(Door shuts)
Especially no coconuts.
Athena:
Attack!
Disarrays are pure chaos.
(Thunderous growl)
Zandra:
Every single thing we sprites
create, Disarrays destroys.
Nobody panic...Ah!
Everybody play dead.
♪♪
This is so adventure-y!
-Hoo-ray!
Hoo-ray...
Woo-hoo!
(Excitement)
♪♪
What do we do now?
We fight!
♪♪
You're not like the others, are
you?
♪♪
Lux:
There's more to you than meets
the eye.
I know who you are...
Zandra:
Wolfboy!
Run!
Lux:
And who you will become.
♪♪